any chance we could start straight  talking honest that's what the policy is  we're going to have in the future in  this party and this movement  I don't believe that a hundred billion  pounds spent on a new generation of  nuclear weapons taking up a quarter of  our defense budget is the right way  forward  it's not acceptable the tories austerity  is the outdated and utterly failed  approach of the past  it didn't help our national security  when we went to war with Iraq in  defiance of the United Nations on a  false protect prospectus it didn't help  our national security to endure the loss  of hundreds of brave British soldiers in  that war  for other people's point of view it's  that sense of fair play these shared  majority values in Britain that are  fundamental reason why I love this  country and its people